oh wow it smells amazing here you just  make curried no spaghetti spaghetti in  like curry no just spaghetti spaghetti  whoa what's up just turn on your magic  operator what so you've never told you  you look like that Indian actress  Priyanka Chopra ooh  tinder avoiding an arranged marriage  always it like The Bachelor on arranged  marriages you just give somebody a rose  no else you look like Mindy Kaling dude  has anybody ever told you you look just  like Aziz Ansari that's a messed up do  it no seriously I only swipe right on  exotic women  thanks for a ride man dude what the hell  your regular driver jack we worked  together  Oh IT guy you fix computers you know I  don't do a whole lot of reading oh you  don't say but I am a scholar when it  comes to the kama Sutra my mustache  [Music]